las calles alrededor de la barrera
fronteriza entre el enclave español de
melilla y marruecos amanecieron en
silencio la calma después de una jornada
muy violenta en la que miles de
emigrantes intentaron entrar en una zona
de control fronterizo tras cortar una
valla sólo unos 500 lograron pasar y
apenas 130 pudieron quedarse al menos de
momento el caos provocó la muerte de al
menos 18 migrantes según españa y
alrededor de 106 heridos entre ellos 49
policías españoles me solidaricé y
reivindica el extraordinario trabajo que
están haciendo las fuerzas y cuerpos de
seguridad del estado en nuestro país
algunas de ellas personas guardias
civiles que fueron heridas como
consecuencia de este asalto violento y
quiero además volver a repetir esa
calificación violento y organizado por
parte de mafias que trafican con seres
humanos
a una ciudad que es un territorio
español sin embargo la asociación
marroquí de derechos humanos dijo que el
enfrentamiento formaba parte de una
intensa represión contra los inmigrantes
desde que las fuerzas españolas y
marroquíes reanudaron las patrullas
conjuntas y reforzaron las medidas de
seguridad en la zona del enclave
este balance duro y catastrófico
demuestra que las políticas migratorias
son mortales
la amdh de nador exige la apertura de
una investigación para determinar las
responsabilidades un día triste nador
que en paz descansen y advirtió de que
no se enterrarán los cadáveres hasta que
se haya investigado adecuadamente como
murieron esta incursión fue la primera a
gran escala desde que españa y marruecos
arreglaron sus relaciones diplomáticas
en marzo cuando el país europeo tras
décadas de neutralidad adoptó una
postura favorable a rabat sobre el
sáhara occidental un territorio
reclamado por marruecos pero en el que
un movimiento independentista respaldado
por argelia exige la creación de un
estado soberano el restablecimiento de
los lazos había supuesto un descenso de
las llegadas de inmigrantes a españa
hasta ahora